une photo de famille pour un
anniversaire à venir celui des 500 ans
de la renaissance dont la préparation
mobilise le conseil régional qui pilote
les opérations
nom de code des festivités viva davinci
le génie italien sera le symbole de cet
anniversaire qui est aussi celui de sa
mort en 15/100 19 au clos lucé à amboise
en fait il ya deux choses
léonard-de-vinci c'est l'homme qui
symbolise dans le monde entier
l'art et la science est vraiment nous
avons des partenariats avec différents
pays et on le sait aussi bien en asie
qu'en europe il symbolise ça il
symbolise une deuxième chose et c'est la
plus importante
il est si on raisonne par rapport à cinq
siècles à l'homme qui a laissé un
patrimoine
mais il est aussi l'homme qui symbolise
le possible il symbolise l'avenir
il symbolise ce qui est la capacité
d'observer d'innover et d'inventer donc
le meilleur de l'homme pour l'occasion
les ateliers de léonard de vinci au
château du clos lucé ont été
reconstitués au terme de trois ans de
recherche
mais cette incroyable visionnaire a
aussi été l'inspirateur indirecte des
plans du château de chambord la demeure
de chasse de françois 1er accueillera en
2019 un sommet franco italien
en présence des chefs d'état des deux
pays en réalité il ya beaucoup de
chantiers qu'on doit faire aboutir pour
2019 qui vont à la fois servir à ce
sommet qui était quand même un motif de
fierté pour pour la région pour le
territoire
et puis aussi pour célébrer les cinq
sens gens et puis tout simplement mieux
toujours mieux accueillir notre public
parce qu on est en pleine croissance et
dont toutes les questions qu'on se pose
c'est comment pouvoir toujours bien à
coeur le public de plus en plus nombreux
une plateforme numérique sera
spécialement dédié à l'ensemble des
manifestations culturelles autour de cet
événement pour lequel la région a
débloqué 2 millions d'euros nous voulons
à partir de cette réalité magnifique
porter à un niveau de connaissance
nationale et internationale à niveau de
rayonnement en effet un niveau de
rayonnement
le niveau de rayonnement qu'elle
méritait donc nous travaillons
aujourd'hui avec l'europe avec les
différents ministères pour que cette
réalité là soit complètement mises en
lumière
signe encourageant avant même que
l'appel à projet soit lancé sans
propositions ont déjà atterri sur la
table du président de la région
[Musique]